god damn it stop [ __ ]
god damn it how's compresses welcome
welcome welcome welcome playing a game
called gas pumping simulator so I work
at a gas station that's cool
Wow the graphics the frame rate IGN
would love this
hi oh jesus [ __ ] christ what happened
I've seen it all now
oh [ __ ] the car needs gas here he left
without gas
hey you I guess I got you aspera I mean
what [ __ ] will you do let me guess you
got your [ __ ] now you're [ __ ]
[ __ ] I'm losing money
god dammit what am i can we get me race
start and we're gonna I'm gonna restart
alright let's give this another go come
on it can't be that hard
Oh Oh I click oh that's why there you go
enjoy your guests sir oh god there's
more already I better help him then oh
god I got I'm so stressed ah no go in ah
jesus [ __ ] christ I is it's an
octopus yes
now I'm losing money again damn it
Oh Andy how hard is it to put it in my
god you [ __ ] he left with it oh my this
[ __ ] game man
all right here
I have that oh you guys wanted to hunt
let me cheat I I never been this
disappointed in my life all right you
just it's like heart bleeding okay I
will not lose any money come back here
you stupid snake put a harelip bake that
off
oh my god stop you're pissing me off
come back here you [ __ ] snake alright
can we have one that is okay okay this
game it's not broken
this is the best game best best game I'm
like 99% sure this game will consume is
all and just eat our souls okay
last chance c'mon bruh as we can do this
we have to make money let's just be fast
I'm gonna be ready where's our first cut
there you are
alright damn it you tricked me goddamn
there we go alright okay that's great
that's no problem no problem as long as
they are not dead they can pay I think
oh god oh god oh god I almost died no
you left with it are you stupid
Oh God the snake is loose the snake is
loose this crappy Oh God
alright son go thanks thanks not know
now I'm losing my leg
yes alright here's a new customer there
you go
you need that gas that's one way ride a
car I guess are you even [ __ ] trying
why
this is so ridiculous alright better gas
this car
oh my god there we go I'm making so much
money though like this is great business
[ __ ] call of duty pumping gas that's
where it's at baby i flying cards baby
that's how your car that's that's how
your car right there right [ __ ] there
pay attention oh sorry be free be free
my friend so I don't know where you
going buddy
where are you going up there
cool this is my new favorite game can I
jump over them
nope alright well hey Ellie you come
from what happens if I just walk off in
the distance
[ __ ] my job I'm gonna be a car to nap
this is this is surprisingly nice I can
I can live with being a car wait this is
my work in soon all right I better get
back to work then I guess son of a [ __ ]
son of a stops pushing you will all get
my cat and then maybe not everyone oh oh
oh oh okay well good thing I have four
more oh it's nine we made $400 yay
best game ever ten out of ten would play
many times again
you